well thanks for coming
my name is stephan herrod and
i'm a research scientist at intel labs
in
sunny santa clara in california so i can
tell you outside it's raining
i had to step outside and actually enjoy
the rain for a bit because i haven't
seen it in months
so uh if you want some rain uh
after this talk is your chance um so
at intel apps i work on river trail
which is our proposal to bring
parallel computing to javascript
and i've done that for probably roughly
the last three years
and i haven't done anything in
javascript before so that was
quite an interesting journey for me and
whenever you want to design something
new
you have to learn what was there before
or
what the the other offerings are so i
had some time in these three years to
actually
look at javascript and understand a
little bit what what concurrency is in
javascript how that works
how parallel computing works and what's
happening in that space
so i'll use the next 35-40 minutes
to share of some of these things i found
particularly interesting um
about concurrency and parallel computing
this talk does not mean to be complete
so there's probably a lot more happening
in that space and i also try to be more
practical than
than giving anything on theory having
said that
one thing i want to put put in front of
you before i actually start is
um something about terminology because i
i see this a lot
and it's it's relatively easy to confuse
the two in everyday language
but there's a big difference between
concurrency
and parallel computing and let's make
that clear before
we kind of dive into these topics so
what is concurrency
and i've tried to to come up with a
definition
and um this is what i what i kind of
distilled out of various online
dictionaries
essentially concurrency is if you
perform multiple tasks
at the same time and you then put
possibly interleaved
but the important thing here is it's
just one single entity performing these
tasks
so in reality there's not really
multiple things happening at the same
time
it's just one entity that has multiple
things to do
and just interleaves them right
so here's an example for you um this is
a concurrent system
and i'm always very amazed when i see
these one-man bands because i would
totally fail at this
but what they do essentially you have
one actor which is the musician here
and he enjoys performing all these
various tasks to create the music
so this is a concurrent system so you
can keep this picture in mind whenever i
say concurrent
so what on the other hand is a parallel
system then
right so parallel computing is if you
have
multiple entities working at the same
time
and they may do the same thing so they
may share a task between them
or they're actually doing multiple tasks
right the first thing is what we often
refer to as something like like data pro
operations where you do the same thing
with multiple entities at the same time
on one piece of data
or in task parallelism you have more the
case of actually having multiple
entities doing different things but
still at the same time
so of course i had to also find a
picture to get this across
so this is an example of a parallel
system right you have multiple entities
the workers here
and they're all performing a task
they're building a car the important
thing is it's actually multiple things
happening at the same time so whenever i
say parallel computing
this is the picture you came back to
okay so the agenda what will i actually
be talking about
so who of you is a web developer or does
web development
that's the large majority that's good so
if you are a web developer you're
actually an expert in writing concurrent
systems
but you might not actually know it
because if you write web applications
you do this even driven asynchronous
programming
which is writing concurrent programs
right you have all these events
and they are somewhat interleaved so
you're performing multiple tasks
but you have one entity that does them
which is your browser
so we'll talk a bit about this event
driven programming and
what how the how the model works and
what the pitfalls in these model are
next i will talk a bit about promises
because uh i have the feeling that's
something that's that's
you know somewhat important to people
currently if i looked at strange looping
there's a lot of talking about async and
all these things
so i thought i'd talk a bit about
promises and why i think they are great
and lastly if you talk about concurrency
on the web
you have to mention web workers there's
no way around it so i will talk a little
bit about
workers too so that will be roughly the
first half of this talk
the second half will be talking about
parallel computing
and the reason why i think this is
important is you're essentially
surrounded by parallel hardware
right no matter what you look at whether
it's a mobile phone a tablet
a laptop a desktop a server anything
really
you will have some parallel hardware in
there
most the any processor today
every processor today has some simple
units inside so they are just ubiquitous
they're everywhere
you have multi-cores right many mobile
phones even have a multi-core system
today
so you better make use of those
multi-cores too and lastly programmable
gpus are really mainstream
and they're becoming more and more
mainstream across the range of devices
so you need to have some story of how
you program these gpus
so that will be the second half of my
talk
okay so with that let's get
into it let's talk about concurrency
although the majority of people here are
web developers i thought i'd first talk
a bit about
how execution actually works in
javascript on a very very high level
so you'll know in javascript you have
the single event queue
so essentially everything that happens
in your browser
has to go through this event queue
eventually and what's very nice about
this programming model
from a conceptual perspective is that
all events
always run to completion before anything
else
is executed right so if you have an
event handler you can really rely on the
fact
that your event handler will complete
before the next event handler starts
and that's a very comfortable space to
be in because you do not have to reason
about what's happening to your global
state because somebody else is mutating
that
it's only you running and you're on your
own there are some exceptions to this
what the dom can do and all these things
but essentially that's your programming
model
another thing you can do which is very
powerful if you are inside of your event
handler
you can actually create new events you
can set a timeout
you can just enqueue event to start
right away sometime after your current
event
so that's what enables you to decompose
a bigger task
into smaller tasks and create this
impression of
a very responsive system by interleaving
all these small tasks
but of course where there's sunnier
there's also shadow
one big drawback of this model i think
is it's non-deterministic
so you never know when what event will
run
and to some part that's just because
it's the web browser and a lot of the
events depend on the outer world
like a user clicking or some response
from the network
so that non-determinism you just cannot
change but also some events are just
under specified so you don't know in
what order they do happen
so you have to live with this
uncertainty never to know what event
handler will run next
i will lose a little use a little
graphic representation during my talk so
i wanted to introduce it to you quickly
i think it's relatively self-explanatory
so this big box is your event queue
and these small boxes are events i use
random colors because it looks good but
they typically don't mean anything
you have this is just some javascript
code you have a mouse event unload event
a timer event
and this little arrow down here that
tells you uh
where execution currently is at right so
that's that's my graphical
representation
so what example do you do if you talk to
people about event-based programming
um what i did i just went to
stackoverflow and asked it you know
what examples do you have so i hope you
can read this even in the back
so there's an example from stack
overflow on asynchronous image loading
so how does that work essentially
what this code does you create this
image object and then you have a url
where you want to load from
and the container where you want to put
that image into once you're done loading
right it's the standard idea of loading
something
after the web page has already rendered
down here is the actual interesting code
so you're assigned to the source
attribute of your image
the url you want to load and that
actually tells the browser hey go fetch
that image
what you also do is you assign this
function here to this unload attribute
which tells the javascript runtime once
this image has loaded and the unload
event
is fired please call this callback
right so how this then runs at runtime
so your above code is running
and eventually it comes to the point
where you assign this url
that will kick off your browser it will
fetch the image
eventually this unload event will appear
because the image has been loaded and
once your execution
reads that unload event
that callback is called and you actually
insert the image
into your website does anyone see any
problem with that
so yeah
so you know seasoned web developer knows
the problem
so here you assign the url first and
then you assign the unload event
so i said you know events always run to
completion so what's wrong with that
where's the problem
the problem is this will instantly fire
off the loading of the image
and if it's in the cache it might
instantly create this onload event
but you have not actually registered
your callback here
so that event will just turn into thin
air
so although this that's the point
although it looks really really simple
you have to be aware of what event
semantics really are
so it's not as simple as you always run
to completion it's still a concurrent
system
you still have some interleavings of
other things in your system happening
and you have to be very very aware of
event semantics
and just to put that right so on stack
overflow the example actually was
correct
so i photoshopped it
you are still allowed to trust the stack
overflow so
be careful with this
this is another way of looking at the
same problem and here
it's it's abstracting a little way from
the code and more looking at the flow of
your asynchronous operation
so what's happening here the idea is you
render first your generic website
that's that's at the top and once that
has completed that's this little arrow
here
you want to run your load image code so
that's the code i showed before
in here you have this this callback that
calls this render image
which is your actually inserting the
image into your
into your website so what you've done
here you have encoded this dependency
in time between the loading of the image
and the rendering of the image
as an unload callback
right there's nothing wrong with that
that's something you know people have
been doing all the time
but let's look at something that's a
little bit more complex than just using
loading a single image so this is an
arbitrary example i just cooked up
because
it kind of puts the point across so what
about you want to do a personalized
website but you don't want to render the
website personalized right away
you want to render a standard website
and then do some asynchronous magic in
the background and eventually
personalize that website for the person
that's viewing it so how would such a
flow look like so you start with your
rendering of the generic website and
then once that's done
um you do a lookup operation yeah you
can think of this like talking back to
your home server
to look up in the database what the user
actually is something like that
once you figure out who that user is you
ask some other services
what they know about this user right so
you could load an avatar image you could
look at social status
you know what's the guy doing on twitter
and facebook and all those
um or you could look up what has
happened on my website recently
right but again these could be all
asynchronous operations you start
once all of them have finished and you
actually have the data you wanted
you can now create your personal view
right so this is just an example of a
more complicated
asynchronous decomposition of a problem
if you do this in the same callback
style that we've seen before
you end up in something that's often
called the callback nesting hell
so you end up in this deeply nested
function definitions
or you have this inversion by defining
all your callbacks first
and then actually putting them into
place later so essentially you destroy
the linearity of your code
so both of that is is ugly but you know
as a web developer you kind of came to
to know how that works you know how to
write code that way and you know how to
recode that way
that's okay but there's a more
fundamental problem with that i believe
and that is if you look at errors
so any of this operation can fail at any
time
right so the lookup could fail because
your web server has gone
some of the social networks decided not
to like you today not to give you any
data
maybe even the rendering of your
personal view fails because you can't
make any sense of that data
right any of these operations can fail
during
the execution of your website so that's
something you have to cater for
and that means you have to have some
error handler
and typically you want to handle the
error down here right you don't care
if it fails anywhere in this pipeline
because there's nothing you can do yes
maybe you can retry
but what's the point just more latency
so what you really want to do is if
anything fails here
you just want to tell the user hey look
it didn't work
so you want to have an error handler
down here so how do you encode that in
your asynchronous flow
well you have to add all these edges and
all these callbacks
for all these operations to their
handler and that's the point
when it really really gets messy right
so you don't want to be
in this situation and that's where i
believe promises
really really help so what's the promise
so the essential idea in promises is
you take this asynchronous flow and you
model it in data
you create objects for every operation
in there and then you model the
dependencies between these objects
so promise objects encodes where an
asynchronous operation is
and it has a couple of methods that
allow you to encode different patterns
of dependency right you can have a
sequence something happens after the
other
some two things can happen at the same
time or you can wait for multiple things
to have happened
right that's some patterns you have but
what's really really great about this
errors propagate along the flow and you
can think of this
like exceptions since in
normal programming if you throw an
exception it just propagates until
somewhere there's
there's catch and you want to have the
same in asynchronous programming you
want to throw an error and then it
propagates along your flow until there's
somebody who cares
and that's what promises give you so
let's look at how you write this
in a promised style so the first thing
you do
[Music]
you create um your your render
which is this operation and it doesn't
return your result and returns your
render promise
so as i said this promise essentially
encodes the state of that operation
and there's three valid states it can be
pending which means
it's still doing it hasn't completed yet
or it's still waiting for something
it can be fulfilled which means it has
done what it was supposed to do
and it produced a valid value or it can
be rejected
which means either it failed or one of
its dependencies failed
so at any time a promise can be in one
of these states and depending on what
state it is
it will do different things
so let's continue with our example here
the next we want to do the lookup and
what we say is
our lookup promise is once you've
rendered then
do the lookup and this then here encodes
that edge
in our asynchronous flow similarly
we do the three interactions down here
so once the lookup has finished then do
the load
or and then do the social and then do
the recent
so you can have multiple edges that go
out
and lastly we have this pattern down
here once all of them has finished
then you want to create your personal
view and here i use wend.js so you can
say
when all of these are done then
do the create it's a very
straightforward way
to implement this asynchronous flow and
to actually
can look at it and understand what it
does
compare this to callback nesting hill
and i think you see the the immediate
advantage
but compare this to how you do error
handling here
so here are your errors
how do i do the error handling here's my
handler
in case you haven't seen the difference
let's highlight it for you you add this
handler down here
and that says when anything fails
somewhere
uh it goes all the way to the first
handler it encounters
and that will just do the magic and do
whatever it needs to do
so this is like exceptions you just say
where you want to catch it and there you
then catch it
okay so this was very short just an idea
about promises there's way more to say
about promises there's a lot of
discussion on promises
i want to point you particularly to
promises a plus which is
the ongoing try to
develop a standard for what a promise
should do
many many libraries implement promises
in in different ways in different
flavors
jquery has something that's somewhat
similar to a promise but not really
so there's a lot of of things out there
you can look at
but i think they will become ubiquitous
in web development
rather soon okay let's switch to another
topic
that was promises who has seen this
window before
yeah that's that's quite a few so i've
put a black box over the url
because i didn't want to embarrass a
particular developer here but um
this is when your web application goes
wrong right so this
is the your web browser is telling you
hey this script is running too long i
can't do anything else
it's actually not me the web browser
who's frozen it's that website's fault
right this is just about blame it's just
the browser vendor saying hey it's not
our browser
so how does this happen
well typically the reason is you have a
very long running event
and as i said before you have this
event-based model
and it enables concurrency but only one
event executes at a time
and that also means that no event is
ever interrupted that's the javascript
concurrency model
so if you look at an example down here
if you really have one of these
big fat events sitting in here that has
a long long running time
all the other events are queuing up
and the underlying problem here is it's
about scheduling granularity
so if you interleave operations in your
queue you never
interrupt any of the events and that
means if you have a long event
your your uh your browser seems to stall
so what do you do about this how do you
fix this and that's
where i think web workers really fit in
nicely that's where you want to have a
web worker
so what is a web worker essentially a
web worker allows you to spawn off a new
instance of the javascript engine
so you get a completely separate
javascript engine conceptually
that can run your code they have no
shared state
so one engine can't see what the other
does which is really nice because it
keeps this
my event is running on its own kind of
property of of the concurrency model
but it also means you have to send
messages across if you want to
communicate data and that's what's
called the actor model
and it also has its own event queue
its own message queue and that's what
really helps if you want to have
concurrency with long-running tasks
why does it help so if you look at the
situation if you have a worker what you
get
you get another worker with another
message queue
and now you can put the long-running
event onto that
message queue and in your main queue all
you do is you send the message
and then you can keep going with your
other events until eventually this long
event has run
sends back a message it's completed and
then you can continue
react to what it's done as i said before
this is concurrent programming right so
you're the one main band
so it doesn't mean that these things run
at the same time
all this really change is it gives you a
different granularity of scheduling
so these two things may now be
interleaved more fines granular so your
your operating might decide to do a
little bit of this then a little bit of
that
then again a bit of this a bit of that
but you just get
better granularity so wet workers make a
lot of sense even if you're not on a
parallel system
okay so that's what i wanted to say
about concurrent programming yeah
uh no so the the main javascript thread
that's where the dom lives and as you
create a new instance that instance
doesn't have a copy of the dom because
you you know you couldn't copy it
there's just one one browser window
so that sits with uh stays with the
browser engine
right but typically if you think about
it the interactions with the dom
are relatively short right you update
something in the dom
that's not a long running operation it's
more like if you have to compute
something complicated or or something
like that or you have something
other complex running on that's when a
web worker makes sense and you want to
sort some data or you have a big hash
table you do something in or these kind
of things
okay so parallel computing
just to remind you again why is this
important um i said
it's everywhere and i think so far in
javascript parallel computing is a
little bit underrepresented
so there's not much happening there
there might be a historic thing so
concurrent programming has been there
way way earlier than parallel
programming right concurrency goes back
you know
all the time i think even the amigo has
said concurrency built in
although there was no parallel hardware
at that time so concurrency is a is a
very old
concept maybe but i think it's time for
the web to to really catch up here
so there's three things that's that's
important to look at you have multi-core
cpus
so you need a story on how to do
something with them
you have simply extensions so you need a
story of you know doing something with
those
and lastly there's this program called
gpus so how do you do something with
them
and i believe really if you want to get
the best experience on a modern device
you have to work with all three of these
so eventually
you will have to write code that uses
all three of these
before coming to something new of course
webworkers also
are a tool in parallel programming right
because they allow you to do task
parallelism
if you run on an actual multi-core
system nobody stops your operating
system from actually
scheduling these two cues on different
cores
and at that point you actually have a
parallel system
and have some parallel computation going
on so this is a great example where
concurrency actually enables parallel
computing
and so what you get here is you
essentially get another
execution unit and both of them now
really execute at the same time
right so if you are on a multi-core web
workers make make sense
even more so let's talk about
another topic let's talk about 7d
programming so who knows what cmd
program is and how it works
okay not everyone so let me give you an
idea so simply the idea is
you typically compute on small vectors
like you have a vector of four or eight
elements
and you perform the same operation on
each element
and that's what cmd stands for it's
single instruction
multiple data doing the same thing for
multiple values
it's a very restricted programming model
so you're only allowed to do the same
operation for every data
so you cannot have complex control flow
so you cannot have a conditional
within a vector computation
but it's very very fast very powerful
because cpus have this built in
directly so if you compute on a four
element vector you can do four additions
say for instance at the same time
okay let's play with this a little bit
to get to get a feeling
so who can envision uh what th this
operation would do
basic math skills anyone yeah
yeah so you get uh three five seven nine
right so you just add element by element
so this this was an easy one
uh how would and who kind of do an and
on those numbers
well i'm just kidding um so and it's the
same thing you do it uh element twice
what's interesting here is you can also
do something like less than
so what does less than do this actually
computes a predicate
so it compares each element in this
vector with each element
in that vector and returns a truth value
so you get a vector of truths
right so one is smaller than 4 2 is
smaller than 3
but 3 is not smaller than 2 and 4 is not
smaller than 1. so this gives you a
vector of boolean values
with those you can do interesting things
you have the select operation
so it essentially gets a vector of these
truth values it gets a vector of values
and another vector of values
and for every element where this is true
it will pick the element here
and for where this is false it will pick
the element there
so the result here should not be too
hard to guess
you pick the first from here so you get
a one the second comes from here you get
a three
the third comes from here you get three
again and the last comes from here
uh so you should get from there actually
should get five
that's another interesting operation
another one that's quite commonly used
is shuffle so shuffle gives you
permutations
another thing you can do on these little
vectors so
this is your shuffle vector and
essentially says on this position of the
result i want to have
that element of the input
okay so in our result we get the third
element
first then the second element the first
element
and the zeroth element so it's counting
from zero um
so this essentially is a reverse
it's just to give you an idea of you
know how simply programming works that's
that's the tools you have
so how do you add simply to javascript
and
there's a proposal by john mccutchen i
hope i pronounced her name right
and essentially what you need to do if
you want to do simply computing first
you need
vectors right so what you do you add
these small vectors to javascript so you
get a float32x4
that's four floats and you get an n32x4
that's four ins another thing you want
you need something to store them in
so that's what you get here with this
float32x4 array you can think of this
like a typed array
but the only difference is it doesn't
contain single numbers it contains
four tuple vectors of those numbers
and lastly now you have these things you
have to compute on them
so that's where your um this
special simply object comes in and
that's very similar to the math object
you already have in javascript
so math defines things like square root
and
simply def similarly defines operations
on simply vectors
so you get your standard things you get
arithmetics uh some binary operations
um some comparison operations uh the
selection shuffle i showed before
and there's some plenty more uh where
you can do
more more bit stuff so really everything
that a modern
cpu architecture has can be reflected in
these intrinsics into javascript
what's important to note here though and
that's that's different to
to the math object typically in
javascript if you store something
like a float32x float in a float32 typed
array
and you read that value back it's
converted to a double
because everything in javascript is a
double that's different here for cindy
so if you read this float32 vector
it stays as a float32
okay here's a simple example
it's a very simple one we start let's
assume we have a and b
which are float32x432 arrays
we create a new float32 array and then
we want to add them
and we do that in this loop and you add
them one element by one element that's
standard javascript
so how do we do this in simde the code
actually is quite similar
[Music]
you now have a float32x4 array as your
input
and you create a new floating tooth 32x4
array
for your output and then you iterate
over the entire length
and all you change you call the simdiad
so this loop will now add four elements
at a time
and everything works out fine and
everything's great this will speed up
greatly
that will convert to doubles
yes that's the that's the the slightly
similar uh semantic difference you have
here this will compute on doubles
this will compute and floats so you have
to be aware of that
okay this is very simple uh let's look
at something that's slightly more
complex
um i've put in a conditional here just
to make this more interesting as i said
before
uh you cannot do conditionals directly
if you program cindy's style
you have to do them in data so how do
you transform this what this does here
if a i is greater than 10 you just sum
up the b's
otherwise you sum up a and b a
straightforward way to do this in
simply is you just compute both of the
branches
right so i compute an x t here
which is adding b and b that's my then
branch
i compute an x e which is adding a and b
that's my else branch
and then i compute a predicate which
decides for every element whether
a i is greater than 10.
i've simplified a bit here because you
would need a vector of tens but that
wouldn't fit on the slides
so once i have this predicate i can then
use my select operation
that should be a p and select the
elements from xt
or xe and i will end up with the same
result
an issue here of course is you have
replicated computation so you're
actually computing
more but as you're computing four things
at a time
you might still be faster so simply
programming isn't easy
easy you know there's a little bit of
wizardry in there to actually figure out
whether it's faster or not
but if you know how it works and
if you know how the performance model
works this can give you great speed ups
so if you want to know more about simdi
there's the proposal i was talking about
that's that's at acma so you can give
your comments it also has a poorly full
implementation which allows you to
actually
run this code and see how it behaves and
there's also some effort from intel and
mozilla excuse me
from intel and mozilla to actually
implement this in firefox so if you look
at this bug number here
you can follow the progress there so
this is programming on small simuctors
the last thing i want to talk about
today is
if you program on a little bit bigger
data than a four element vector
and that's where river triple comes in
that's what i'm working on
and that kind of closes this this
relatively long story this morning
so how do you program if you have
more than four elements if you actually
have an array
and the ideas are very similar to simply
programming
so the difference is we now operate on
n-dimensional arrays right instead of a
four-element vector we have arrays
that might contain further arrays
and we still perform the same operation
every element of these arrays
mostly right we also do reductions and
things like that but mostly it's the
same kind of idea
and this is designed not for simply
units although it might auto
vectorize and actually run on your
assembly unit but this is with
multi-core cpus and gpus in mind
so what does it look like this has
gone through a lot of iterations and we
got a lot of great feedback but it's
still open for feedback so if you have
some please talk to me
but right now it's an extension of
javascript array objects
and the upcoming typed objects which
were formerly known as binary data
and essentially what we've done is we've
added six new methods
which all end in this nice word par
which
tries to hint you that this is a
parallel primitive
so we have build par which allows you to
construct an array in parallel
we have mappar which is like the
javascript map
but it runs in parallel similarly we
have reduce power
then we also have scan which is a nice
primitive you want to do things like
prefix sums similar operations
we have scatter which is for
permutations so if you have an array and
you want to move elements around then
scatter is your friend
and finally we have filter which allows
you to drop elements from an array
so these are the essentially the six new
primitives we give you so let's look at
a very simple example
increment right so we start out with
this array up here
and then we call this mappar function
which
gets a function which we call the
elemental function as its argument
which given an element computes the new
element
right and everybody of you who has done
javascript programming before
and has used map will say right away
this looks like map
so this is the standard javascript map
and yes they look
very similar except for these three
letters but there's a big semantic
difference
this one here the javascript standard
one
runs left to right whereas this one here
on top
runs in any order and potentially in
parallel
so how do we make this happen there's
one big property we need
to allow for parallel execution and
that's really the big new concept that
parallel javascript or vivitrol
introduces
and that's temporal immutability
so the idea here is that while your
elemental function your pedal code is
running
it is not allowed to mutate the global
heap
so the global heat becomes temporarily
immutable
you're not allowed to change it so let
me show you an example for this
here it is my increment again so this is
a very contrived way to write increment
in javascript
but it's actually legal so what does
this do
again you do a map and you apply this
function and it now gets the value and
the index
and you do a plus plus on
ai which is a side effect here to this
global a
and return the value so what this does
it returns an array
that has every value incremented but as
a nice side effect
also increments every value in the
original array
this is valid javascript code i'm not
saying you should write it but it's
valid javascript code
it's not valid for parallel execution
though because this
is mutating the global state so this
elemental function here
is not temporally immutable so this will
not run in parallel
will be rejected by your browser
okay let's look at another example sum
so this is sum
for sum we use reduce again you get a
function with two l
and you get two elements a and b and you
return the sum of the two
so what this does this computes the sum
of all elements
of the input array again this looks very
similar to the javascript reduce
but there's a fundamental difference in
the javascript reduce
if you look at the specification it says
the first argument
is the previous value and the second
argument is the current value
you even get an index where you're
currently at in parallel execution we
don't have any of these concepts
because other than the sequential case
which doesn't reduce left
to right we may reduce this in any order
so we cannot tell you which one is the
previous which one is the current
it might even be that some of these
values are nowhere to be found inside of
the array because there are some
arbitrary intermediate sums
another important thing is this function
has to be a social different commutative
to allow for arbitrary reorderings so if
you want to make sure that you always
get the same result when running in
parallel
you have to make sure that property is
fulfilled
so lastly let me give you a slightly
more complex example that makes use of
typed objects
so who has seen type objects binary data
before
ah it's getting fewer and fewer so
let me give you an example so what the
goal in typed object is you can think of
it a bit like
typed arrays and steroids so the idea is
you take typed arrays and you extend
them to be
nested arrays and you extend them to
also have c like structures
and then essentially you have typed
objects so what we do here
we declare two types so pixel is
an array type of u and eight so you can
think of this as a four element typed
array
an image is an array type of array type
of pixel
so this is a two dimensional array that
has four element arrays inside
so this is how you would represent rgb
alpha image
typically on the web right this is
what's in canvas so let's assume we have
this kind of image
and we just get it using this get image
function here
so how do we compute something like
grayscale on this in parallel
and grayscale is a pixel to pixel
operation right you take a pixel
you compute the grayscale value and that
gives you your new pixel
so this is how you write it you take the
image you do a parallel map
and you get this new thing here which is
this number two that's the depth
so you have to tell map how deep you
want to iterate
if you have a nested array you could
iterate over the rows that's the depth
of one
but if you want to see every pixel you
want to iterate over the two outermost
dimensions
and that's a depth of two so this will
go over all pixels and then for every
pixel call this function
and this function just computes the
luminance out of the r g and b values
and returns a new pixel which has the
luminance and we just pass through the
alpha channel
so this is how you do grayscale and we
played a lot with this kind of operation
so we implemented
game physics we did some computer vision
algorithms we did 3d animations
and you can get really really decent
speed ups
we have a prototype that's available on
github so if you want to play
with that it has slightly different api
but it gives you
an idea of how it would perform on a gpu
too
so if you want to have more mozilla is
actually implementing this
in a joint project with us innightly so
if you download nightly you can start
playing at least with the array part
of the api and there's also the ecma
proposal out so we've written a proposal
to put this into javascript
and it's very open for comments also
you can look at the typed objects
proposal that's for the next version of
ecmascript
which we build on so that's that's a
building block and that concludes my
talk
so i hope i i've shown you that
concurrency
is just a given on web development so
it's everywhere
you have to be aware of event semantics
promises i think are a great way to
encode errors and do error handling
and web workers think about web workers
for long-running tasks
also parallel computing it's becoming
more and more important
so you should start looking into it
web workers for toss parallelism right
now
cmd is coming so if you have small
computations on vectors
take a look at simply and lastly
parallel javascript
um if you have some larger scale
operations on array
so with that thank you i think i'm out
of time but you can catch me afterwards
for questions